but you look amazing tell me about the
other hat it's about 1:00 or so so yeah
okay Christmas like I'm getting into the
spirit getting into the spirit on the
red carpet I love it um how cool does it
feel to be on this carpet to be seeing
the movie with the cast altogether like
is this gonna be a good experience for
you guys I think so you know I saw it by
myself a little theater in Atlanta a
couple of weeks ago and I haven't seen
those girls and forever be fun he's got
their dolls of like it's not kind of
cool everybody has action figures and
dolls from this movie it's sort of fun I
know I've never had that you know and
we're all advocating for them to be made
public please
you mentioned Christmas feeling festive
what are your holiday traditions gonna
be a little Christmas with the fam this
year will it be special yeah it'll be
special you know baby's first Christmas
and you know we just moved into a new
home so yeah we just want to be home and
light a fire baby's first Christmas that
has to feel like are you gonna be
emotional super grateful and thankful I
already am every day is special you know
I'm actually motional being away from
her for the first time so I'm looking
forward to come home but yeah just I
love Christmas and I wanna just be
cooking and you know sit on the couch
with my baby and my man yeah they must
be so proud of you being here tonight
they are oh the liberation he's ready
for me to come home how long have you
been gone just two days but still that
was your first time away from I'm mama
how is it it's still a little stressful
yeah I thought you posted I think around
Thanksgiving just that you're so
grateful for him and where you're at it
was so sweet has he been blown you away
as a father does that love just deepen
yeah you know he's already been he had
he's done this before so he's really
experienced and he
just me a lot and he's a great with our
and she's light of your life I'm
guessing yeah of course this is very
special 2018 is wrapping down as a year
if you could describe the year in one
sound what would it be
[Music]